foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we seem to be losing the last bilateral
relationship governing nuclear weapons
so we could have an arms race after this
and that arms race has not existed
because of this agreement because of the
inspections that back up the
intelligence that both states have and
so you have one of those pillars being
taken away
ministers
foreign
[Music]
Russia has demonstrated that it is a
Serial violator of Arms Control
agreements it has violated nearly every
agreement it has been in since uh Putin
came to power so from the U.S
perspective why should we trust Russia
in any future agreements and of course
the Russians make similar allegations
against the United States you know the
United States has withdrawn from a few
Arms Control agreements so there's
really a lot of distrust on both sides
it's going to make it a real challenge
her arms control as we know it to have a
future
[Music]